s - puis il faut je vous parlerai la
guerre de l'amour et la mort essoufflé
maud le pladec à londres la jeune femme
ne cesse de parcourir la vie le monde et
la danse à la vitesse d'un sprinteur
mais avec l'endurance d'un coureur de
front la voici en ce moment nouvelle
directrice du centre chorégraphique
national d'orléans et à la veille de
présenter son dernier spectacle en date
motocross motocross et un solo données
sur un ring à projets intime un hommage
un fait biographiques et un retour dans
la bretèque des années 80 de son enfance
on m'a de cross et c'est lié à mon
enfance puisque
mon père était président du moto club de
saint brieuc mon frère lui faisait aussi
beaucoup de motos et on a en fait j'ai
accompagné toute la famille a accompagné
mon frère et mon père sur les
compétitions depuis l'âge de mes 6 ans
jusqu'à ce que finalement je dise je
n'en peux plus donc de fait à peu près
j'étais ado et que je dise vous partez
dimanche mais moi je restais à l'année
[Musique]
bien côté affiche de l'autre deux
garçons peint sur le camion j'apporte un
tutu rose mon frère une combinaison d'un
côté la suite de l'autre le garçon mon
père avait un camion qui était à 7,35
qu'il avait aménagé pour qu'on puisse
tous partir sur les terrains de
compétition sur lequel il avait dessiné
d'un côté une danseuse à tutu rose et de
l'autre côté une moto qu'ils aient une
roue arrière donc sa fille et son garçon
et c'était très clair que c'était la
fille et le garçon mais c'était aussi
très clair pour moi à l'époque et
pourtant j'étais très jeune que cette
danseuse à turow ce n'était pas la
danseuse que j'avais envie d'être là non
petites ballerines fait alors de la
chorégraphie son espace d'émancipation
de liberté et de plaisir
deux écoles de danse financé à crédit
puis elle fonde sa propre compagnie en
quelques créations maud le pladec
s'impose sur la scène chorégraphique
française et internationale aujourd'hui
motocross retourne aux sources
c'est intéressant pour moi de revenir
sur ces faits biographique sur ce récit
de vie et c'était aussi un projet
évidemment à l'hommage faire en hommage
à mon père qui est disparu faki iec
décédé depuis et qui ne m'a jamais vu
devenir la danse ce que je suis
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
dans ce sens peut danser ensemble
nourrira somme mais ne ramène moi
[Musique]